est-ce que tu as envie de me raconter un
peu ce poster à gauche je pense que tu
peux le comprendre c'est c'est mon côté
sombre ouais mes défauts mes vices
maises les choses que que j'aime pas en
moi mais qui sont présents en moi et qui
font du mal et qui qui font partie de ma
vie et à droite les côtés qui me font du
bien d'amour mon côté un peu plus un peu
plus joyeux rose que que j'ai aussi
qu'est-ce que ça représente le feu pour
toi on dit que l'eau compose le corps à
72 % moi c'est le feu je pense qui
compose mon corps à 80 à 72 % voilà
parce que je suis pas heureux parce que
je me je suis pas épanoui je suis pas je
suis pas heureux vraiment est-ce que ce
feu en toi peut se transformer
j'espère c'est pas grave c'est normal
t'inquiète
pas j'espère dans l'Évangile on dit par
exemple ta parole est un feu dévorant
c'est que le feu il peut être comme
cette image peut tout détruire mais le
feu c'est aussi la puissance de vie qui
est en toi moi je sais que j'ai un feu
moi je su je suis très sportif
j'ai j'ai une rage de vaincre que je
l'ai au fond de moi donc je parle du feu
de manière comme ça mais oui j'ai un
fond moi qui est bon aussi c'est que
j'aimerais qu'il soit plus
[Musique]
présent